that's my new favorite catchphrase yes
we can hop fun was a regular laughed my
head off when they said this is a new
character it's called do kaboom yeah
he's the one beer number one spoke man I
said I'm
was it cool working with Keanu Reeves
well we don't I I did not meet Keanu
Roos until they took a picture with a
whole cast about a month ago we don't
you don't work together I was terrified
to work with them I just thought John
wick four or three I go good lord I
don't want to get this guy upset keep
them away from the knives we hear about
how great he is they might show us you
know like a little clip of something
that he did but you don't actually you
know you know you don't get to interact
with the other cast members on Toy Story
movies you imagine them which kind of
like drives you it kind of little nutty
I got in a course of all by yourself in
your mind you see these people and you
have visions of what they are that's
someone gets stuck in my head thank you
we're watch the movie you okay okay
that's fake hair get it well you know
cuz I can see your life
that in the second one they said at the
end of today's session you're gonna
you're going to sing the song because in
what he said and I had never been more
terrified and God bless him we did
literally one and a half takes it okay
we got it the end of it Robert Goulet
sang it by way out of out of wheezy's
mouth what does it mean for you to bring
this movie back after 9 years since Toy
Story 3 to a whole new generation I was
sitting there with my kids and they were
getting all the same feels what does
that mean well they did I'd like to hear
that
I don't it's a labor of import yeah we
don't take it lightly no not at all no
because the Pixar people the geniuses
they don't take it lightly when they we
don't bang out these Toy Story movies
they take a long time in order to in
order to simmer and kind of like decide
whether or not it's worth doing at all
you know what is it gonna be good enough
no one wants to have an okay toys story
movie out there but they have a lot to
live up to and I'm looking at this that
everyone gets better and better and how
do you do this and me III find it very a
very courageous they come out and do
this again it's so beautiful and it
brings back memories you're kind of like
the age you were when you saw the first
one yeah that's right so you you you you
your daughter what you have my
daughter's 12 in nine 12 yeah so she
will always be 12 when she sees any Toy
Story movie she gets to go back I guess
she's seen the original ones as well but
if you're say you're four years old or
five years old then you're seeing Toy
Story 4 you might not have seen the
other ones and you know no matter how
old you are you'll still be five years
old when you see the most beautiful and
it brings back memories I was thinking
about my kids going to kindergarten for
the first time and how that was you
remember that do you remember bring it
do you remember your kids going back to
school and having those toys those
attachments does that bring you back
just like just dropping them off on the
first day and watching them enter into
the beginning of the really the rest of
their lives
take took me right out at the kneecaps I
hated every minute oh I've never
bringing this up said but it's the same
exact feeling you see when they walk
across the in their in their college
graduation go oh they picked it back up
but low and now it's back oh well you
know the emotion goes like this is like
a roller coaster it's kind of like a Toy
Story movie rot rot - rot large yeah but
the first one wasn't sad at all was it
you know because that was all about play
nice
no right no yeah it was like a just the
standalone movies it's like read words
it did that stop with it stop
[Applause]